and finally new rule let's hit pause on
this growing consensus among Democrats
that we can only beat Trump in 2020 by
running a celebrity of our own how did
we go in two years from wow it could be
a celebrity - it can only be a celebrity
when I asked my Democratic friends about
the plan for 2020 they say two things
what's a plan and we need a star that's
it the blueprint for saving us from
fascism is rub a lamp and hope Tom Hanks
pops out or Oprah but if if if Oprah is
president who will tell cat ladies what
to read
[Applause]
The Rock says he hasn't ruled out
running in 2020 but if the rock is
president who's gonna star in every
movie ever made especially movies with
the premise that movie except with the
rock like towering inferno with the rock
King Kong with the rock Jumanji with the
rock
Baywatch with the rock walking tall with
the rock earthquake with how about the
rock if he did run his hat would say we
make America great again
many Democrats feel they found star
quality in Mike 11 Eddie
he's like if the hot felon had a law
degree and it's great the way he makes
shrubs on Matty can pronounce his name
right just reported by a sleazebag
lawyer named Abbiati
[Applause]
obby auntie are you always thinking
about pasta look I understand the
temptation to pick a celebrity after all
Trump started with a big advantage
because he was a household name like
spam or preparation age and in today's
political atmosphere where substance
makes you an elitist and experience
means you're part of the swamp it's like
the whole country just went [ __ ] it the
government can't do anything which
candidate will give us the most laughs
and it wasn't even close
[Applause]
Donald Trump has no friends no one will
tell him when he has [ __ ] toilet
paper uninsured
I mean look at him he will do anything
for a laugh
[Applause]
I'm very presidential
but when the prime directive for
government goes from keep us safe to
keep us entertained that's bread and
circuses end of the Empire stuff there
are people who actually excited about
Kanye West in politics these people are
called idiots
he's eccentric they say no he's standing
in the punchbowl [ __ ] the ice
sculpture
[Applause]
the Democrats the Democrats message in
2020 should be let's get back to normal
and president ariana grande does not
send that message of course celebrities
and politics isn't new but it was always
something mostly Republicans did Reagan
Schwarzenegger Sonny Bono game show host
Donald Trump the party that endlessly
proclaims its disdain for Hollywood will
literally run any celebrity who's a
conservative and it wasn't that long ago
they were using the word celebrity as a
burn he's the biggest celebrity in the
world is he ready to lead turns out he
was ready to lead
[Music]
because he wasn't black Paris Hilton he
was a politician government was his
skill his life his calling like the
Kennedys before him an FDR he was a star
but a star because of what he
accomplished in office yes Obama enjoyed
his TV time but he didn't just sell
policy not to do robot voice Trump
doesn't need to do Fallon because he is
Fallon
Republicans elect a celebrity who
becomes a politician Democrats at their
best elect a politician who's so good at
public service they become a celebrity
[Applause]